[Music]
on this thursday night air canada hopes
to land a bailout
how refunds could be waiting in the
wings for customers
as the airline negotiates with ottawa
more hope on the horizon the growing
optimism more canadians will be
vaccinated
sooner federal government sides with
commercial
fissures i think that path takes right
down colonization
the new chapter in a dispute over
indigenous fishing rights
and battle royale i don't know
how they could expect we would still
just be silent
new accusations from meghan markle
against buckingham
[Music]
global palace with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
anyone who loves to travel can't wait to
get back on the move and those who are
still waiting for refunds for old
airline tickets
are still wondering when or if they'll
get their money back
there are hints tonight air canada is
moving closer to refunding thousands of
passengers but
only if it gets a bailout from the
federal government negotiations with the
airlines have been going on for months
our chief political correspondent david
aiken has been asking questions about
what progress
has been made and he has our top story
tonight
just couldn't give me a refund and i
find that absolutely
unbelievable terry kiros is like
thousands of canadian airline passengers
frustrated and angry that
airlines have still not returned money
paid for flights not taken
because of the pandemic westjet has had
a refund program of sorts in place since
the fall and now
air canada is promising the same says
one of air canada's unions
but only if the airlines get access to
federal government cash
but ottawa wants more from the airlines
than just a promise to refund
unused tickets there was a lot of issues
you know that had to be dealt with
including the you know the controversial
issue of air canada
repaying the customers so these issues
have all been dealt with from what i
understand
we're talking large money we're talking
a loan not a bailout
indeed unifor says one option on the
table was a loan to the airlines
worth seven billion dollars to be repaid
over ten years with a minimal interest
rate of
one percent a year the terms of that
financial arrangement are still not
settled and indeed that may be the
sticking point
when negotiations began in november the
trudeau government said it also wanted
commitments from the airlines
to restore service to routes that were
cut or dropped
and it wants to protect or restore jobs
in the airline sector
no one could say when a deal will get
done though
one federal minister catherine mckenna
said good
progress is being made we've been really
clear that refunds
are a precondition to any deal that is
extremely important we all hear from
canadians
who want to be compensated we want to
get their refunds
airline passengers though are frustrated
with the delay
the federal government has proven to be
unreliable and untrustworthy
and worthy of the public trust in terms
of enforcing passengers rights
david aiken global news ottawa there is
growing optimism more canadians could
get vaccinated sooner than originally
expected
with more provinces moving to extend the
time between the first and second doses
and the prospect of more vaccines being
approved every canadian who wants one
might get one before the end of
september
there is still a long way to go though
right now more than 1.6 million
canadians have received at least one
dose
that works out to just over four percent
of the population
and just over 550 000 people are now
fully vaccinated
with two doses delaying the second dose
by four months will mean more canadians
get at least some protection with one
dose
sooner mike lacature explains what more
we know about those shifting timelines
we expect that our timelines will be
reduced overall
ontario's health minister believes more
people will be able to get their first
vaccine
sooner than originally expected federal
officials had set
september as the target time for when
every canadian
could get at least one dose of the
covid19 vaccine
but new guidance from the national
vaccine advisory panel
suggesting a longer lag time between
doses means more people could be
protected
earlier we would be able to cover uh you
know the
vast majority of the clean population
that or the same population in a
sort of in a sort of a advanced timeline
or moving it up by
several weeks when pressed dr knew
refused to be more precise but one
atlantic premier
already has a date circled on the
calendar we should be able to get every
nova scotian
their first dose by the end of june
saskatchewan is looking
at the same time frame now the
accelerated timeline
is also being helped by increased
delivery of
vaccines it's expected canada will get
769
000 doses of the pfizer biontec vaccine
per week
for the first two weeks of april and 1.3
million doses of the moderna shot
are coming in the next two weeks still
premiers complain
it hasn't been quick enough i do not
think it's acceptable that canada is
44th in the world in per capita
administration of covet-19 vaccines i
think it's a
embarrassment a part of that could be
due to vaccine hesitancy which
is a problem in every country and
officials know
it's an uphill battle when there are
changes to guidelines
like for the time between doses
definitely the messaging would be
simpler
if we had one set of data and we had one
message and it never changed
but that's not what science does people
have to understand science is an
evolving thing
what is true today may be altered
tomorrow
when we learn some something more the
health canada says approval of the
single-dose johnson and johnson vaccine
should be coming
within the next week however delivery of
those shots
may only start in april at the earliest
donna okay michael couture in ottawa
tonight thanks
hell canada is taking steps to fast
track the approval of booster shots
for the new variants of concern the
agency says if manufacturers have
already approved vaccines come out with
a booster shot they will
not have to go through a brand new
approval process instead they will have
to provide proof
showing the booster is safe and
effective the move by health canada
should help speed up the rollout
if updated vaccines are developed
in edmonton a senior's home is facing
serious questions after an outbreak
involving
one of the highly contagious variants so
far 36 staff and residents at the
churchill manor have tested positive
for the virus at least 19 are confirmed
variant cases
the daughter of one of the residents who
tested positive says the home began
easing covet 19 rules two weeks ago
before residents were fully vaccinated
i don't know what made them do this but
someone has to be accountable
because there's no doubt in my mind that
the covet came in because they opened
everything up too fast
a company that operates churchill manor
told global news it did start easing
rules in mid-february
precautions were escalated after the
first positive case
the company says they are doing
everything possible to protect residents
and staff an ontario doctor has been
formally cautioned by regulators for
spreading
misinformation about covid19 online
dr colvinder gill was issued three
separate cautions by ontario's college
of physicians and surgeons
after complaints over a series of
comments she made on twitter
according to the college gill wrote
there is absolutely no medical or
scientific reason for this prolonged
harmful and illogical lockdown
and she tweeted if you have not yet
figured out that we don't need a vaccine
you are not paying attention in its
decisions the college said it has no
interest in shutting down free speech
it called gil's tweets inappropriate
unprofessional
and a potential risk to public health
all physicians hold a position of trust
in our society as members of the college
and the college expects physicians to
behave
professionally gail could not be reached
for comment as part of her discipline
she must attend the college to receive a
verbal caution
about her conduct for more details on
that case we have a full story on our
website globalnews.ca
canada's premiers met virtually today
and though they disagree on lots of
things
they were unanimous about one thing
wanting more health care funding from
the federal government
the premiers say issues that existed
before covid19 have been exacerbated by
the pandemic
manitoba's premier warns a post pandemic
pileup is coming because elective
surgeries
tests and other procedures have been
delayed
according to the canadian institute of
health information before covet struck
us
the wait times had grown in the last 20
years by about two and a half
times meaning you used to wait from
general practitioner to treatment about
two months now you wait closer to six
months
this isn't the prime minister's fault
except if he ignores the problem
and then it becomes his fault the
premiers want the federal government to
increase its share of health care
funding to 35 percent which would add
about
28 billion dollars and bring the federal
share to 70 billion
prime minister justin trudeau has
acknowledged the federal share must
eventually increase
but he has told premiers that we'll have
to wait until after the pandemic
there is a major development tonight in
the dispute over indigenous
fishing rights in this country the
federal government has announced a new
plan to regulate how and when
indigenous fisheries can operate it has
been a contentious
issue in nova scotia that at times has
turned violent
as ross lord reports it's still not
clear if this
will resolve that tense situation
[Applause]
amid the tension and violence
surrounding indigenous fishing rights
a voice both sides blamed for being
indecisive has finally taken a position
fisheries minister bernadette jordan is
siding with commercial fissures on a key
issue
when first nations harvesters are
entitled to fish
in a statement jordan says these
fisheries will operate within
established seasons
she says integrating everyone into the
same season using
already available licenses makes sense
the seasons are something that we have
in order to make sure stocks stay
plentiful
to make sure that stocks are sustainable
jordan says she will license first
nations fisheries
ensuring they can sell their lobsters
legally she calls it a path
forward but the chief of the sebagon
agony first nation
whose members were subjected to violent
protests last fall
suggests it's a step in the wrong
direction i think that path takes right
down
colonization for us it's very
discouraging what
she said and it was even hard to believe
and hard to read that she would even try
to pull out on us
very unfortunate the assembly of nova
scotia migma chiefs also opposes the
plan
and they're not alone the federal ndp
accuses the government of failing to
uphold migma
treaty rights and dalhousie fisheries
researcher megan bailey says
the minister should not be telling migma
when to fish she should be moving over
and making space to support migma
governed
moderate livelihood plants a group that
represents commercial fishers supports
jordan
while admitting the number of indigenous
lobster traps is tiny
compared to the number fished by its
members what may seem as a small
fishery last year could have eventually
evolved into a huge
fisheries access jordan has still not
defined the term
moderate livelihood the rights of
indigenous fishers to fish for one are
protected by a 1999 supreme court
decision but chief sacks says
he's not concerned about that omission
no we're actually going to
define that ourselves sac says sebagon
negative harvesters will be out fishing
again in the spring
regardless of what the fisheries
minister says or does
ross lord global news washington d.c
on high alert coming up new threats of
violence at the u.s capitol
plus a perfect landing turned explosive
the launch was flawless elon musk's
starship
rocket had a perfect test flight this is
a prototype of a
reusable rocket it's hoped will one day
take humans and cargo to the moon and to
mars
its landing looked amazing and appeared
to be perfect
but there were flames at the base of the
rocket and about eight minutes later
this happened the unmanned rocket
exploded the fact it landed in one piece
though is considered a success
there will be many more test flights
elon musk wants his rockets flying
people regularly by 2023
and tweeted rip sn 10
honorable discharge in washington tight
security is still in place because of
fears of a repeat of the violence
earlier this year at the u.s capitol
trump supporters and conspiracy
theorists believe march 4th
was the day that he would return to
power and as our washington bureau chief
jackson proskow reports
this time police are taking no chances
the threat was serious enough to station
extra troops behind the razor wire and
for the house to cancel all business for
the day
we do have some concerning intelligence
that intelligence is law enforcement
sensitive
a bulletin from the fbi and homeland
security warned
this was a target date for violent
groups who talked about taking control
of the u.s capitol
and removing democratic lawmakers a plot
eerily reminiscent
of the january sixth attack we have to
ensure with our security that
we are safe enough to do our job
in pro-trump circles march 4th is
important
it's the date followers of the q anon
conspiracy theory believe the former
president would return
and be inaugurated for a second time the
plan
that they believe in and the kind of
storm that they're waiting for
has simply not materialized in any
meaningful way
julian field hosts a podcast that
investigates q anon
he warns followers are rarely dissuaded
by false predictions
and could turn to violence out of
frustration when
those hopes are dashed they could be
moved to either individual or collective
action
that's precisely what has law
enforcement so worried
this week the fbi director revealed
there are 2 000 active investigations
underway
into domestic terrorists white
supremacists and far-right militias
the problem of domestic terrorism has
been metastasizing across the country
for
a long time now and it's not going away
anytime soon
do you miss me yet do you miss me much
of it links directly to donald trump's
lies about a stolen election
which the former president refuses to
tamp down actually as you know they just
lost the white house but
it's one of those things understanding
that the potential threat could be long
term
u.s capitol police have asked the
national guard to remain in place for
the next two months
the fencing and razor wire could be here
even longer
donna okay jackson prosco in washington
thanks
ahead how much can protesters in myanmar
endure as they fight against the
generals who seize power
that is the sound of a tsunami warning
in new zealand people raced for higher
ground after three powerful earthquakes
struck
off the coast of new zealand several
tsunami warnings have been issued there
and at one point
there was even a warning for the coast
of british columbia that has now ended
the largest quake was a magnitude 8.1 it
struck northeast of new zealand's north
island
at 8 30 in the morning the generals who
seized power in myanmar are now
overseeing a bloodbath
security forces are shooting protesters
on the streets
at least 38 people are reported to have
been killed by soldiers and police on
wednesday
the harshest crackdown since the coup in
february
tonight the faces of those killed
sparked a new flash point for
pro-democracy demonstrators
demanding the military stand down and
return the civilian government to power
eric sorenson reports and a warning some
of the images in his story
are graphic a man takes these pictures
of a patrol
a soldier spots him the shot missed
but myanmar's military has clearly taken
aim and would prefer no one sees what's
happening
in the civilian protests against the
military's coup was a nineteen-year-old
known as angel
keal sin wore a t-shirt that said
everything will be okay
she was shot in the head and killed the
u.n
has counted 54 protesters killed but
believes the real number is much higher
it is utterly abhorrent that security
forces are firing live ammunition
against peaceful protesters across the
country myanmar also known as burma has
long been shrouded from the outside
world
elections have only been held since
2010. when popular leader aung san
tsuchi's party won a landslide vote in
november
over candidates backed by the army
military leaders
slammed the door shut on democracy
yet a younger generation of
demonstrators who want real change are
not backing down
myanmar is very different today than it
was in the past this coup has really
mobilized resistance against them
against the military in a way that we
haven't seen before
the international community is imposing
limited sanctions our measures are going
to continue
to be very tightly targeted at the
members of their
of the military experts say that will
help but the real difference may be
what's happening on the ground
where political groups and government
workers and different religious leaders
are finding common cause
[Applause]
it's our right to get democracy they
chant
we may be seeing in some ways the start
of a more comprehensive a deeper or
farther reaching revolution
than than what we've had in myanmar
before kial sin
angel is the latest hero to be mourned
by the people of myanmar
emotions are intense despondence over
the dead
fortitude and fury in the streets and
when the bullets fly
fear for their lives
but it seems they'll keep coming back
eric sorensen global news
toronto next allegations against the
duchess
of sussex are they signs of a royal
family feud
there is an update tonight on prince
philip's health buckingham palace says
the 99 year old duke of edinburgh
has undergone a successful procedure for
a pre-existing heart condition
he's expected to stay in hospital for
several more days of rest
and recuperation while the queen worries
about her husband's health another
family drama is erupting
cbs has now released another teaser from
that
upcoming tell-all interview with the
queen's grandson prince harry and his
wife megan
she tells oprah winfrey buckingham
palace's perpetuating falsehoods about
her and harry
and as redmond shannon reports the
couple who said they wanted to withdraw
from the limelight
are putting themselves right back into
it
relations between the royal relations
were bad enough already
and then came this new preview clip from
oprah winfrey's interview
i don't know how they could expect
that after all of this time we would
still just be silent
if there is an active role that the firm
is playing
in perpetuating falsehoods about us
the firm a euphemism for the royal
family
this week just after the first oprah
clip was released
a newspaper report alleged the duchess
of sussex faced allegations of
bullying in kensington palace in 2018.
a response from buckingham palace
wednesday said the royal household will
not tolerate bullying or harassment
in the workplace for more than a year
the palace and the sussexes have tried
to paper over the cracks of their
difficult relationship
at least in public but now there can be
little doubt
but that this is a family feud one
newspaper summed it up very well i think
this morning when they called this
all-out war at the palace
royal expert phil dampier says the
allegations against megan had been
rumored
but the timing of the report is probably
no coincidence
obviously people at the palace are
trying to get there get their punch in
first as it were
but it's very very sad because of course
this is all against the background of
prince philip being
in hospital a sadness shared by some
londoners
whatever we've been hearing it's just
not nice
nice not for the monarch not for the
country not for anyone it's a shame
anyway when siblings
are a loggerheads i think it's such a
shame whatever family they come from
the full interview oprah with megan and
harry
airs sunday evening on global redmond
shannon global news
london and that's global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's euro canada is late nipissing
a remnant of the glacial lake algonquin
near west nipissing ontario
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email us yours
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]